hello and welcome to this video playing
nothing wrong
oops pre moving okay yeah let's see what
she has in store against winner three
probably nothing as it is usual there is
a pretty nice surprise weapon that
normally people have no particular
recipe against let's see five yeah magic
it's not the only move but it's a decent
one immediately I'm going for them weak
and dark squares and he says I don't
give a peep okay yeah that's a nice
position forward can always open up the
a file at will and it's very very
comfortable let's push this for possible
g5 it looks a little bit odd that I'm
not developing but you really don't need
to at the moment like has no particular
particularly good option available okay
so I don't need to take them doubling on
the edge farm now is also quite
attractive not totally certain
if I should be wishing we should do with
this okay I'll play it like six yeah
maybe just be three if it takes on a
form and I just recapture
[Music]
interesting but I can go see three yeah
there's nothing wrong about it okay a
five he would go to the seven and
potentially two to f8 if he takes
I've got before and then we should be
three that is a strategically quite good
situation so I can do this as well I
mean kind of inflexible he I don't need
to play on the edge for
not easy to give black eye good advice
there
just taking on a four was quite
promising as well but that still looks
quite good so now we cannot move a or
see porn and my idea c4 c5
No okay so it looks fun taking on v6 and
on a 4s probably too lame not exactly
what I expected that he would walk right
into into a fork they're almost okay
I'll go to the seven I guess now do I
just take yeah I guess I do
and here just okay five him
the apron should win
which is too far to fly away plus I'm
playing with the king and black isn't so
that's the kind of game you want from
the Queen f3 g3 setup just a very
comfortable better ending but probably
resigning I don't don't see one else
no it's not very difficult
having said that how do I win Oh
how do I win ders
[Music]
oh yeah I should just first
yeah they took me a while but I found a
way to win the straightforward way to
win now you walk all the way to g4
okay so I think that was a really
comfortable position out of the opening
after queena three black of course has a
couple of options I think Knight f6 is
probably best that's what I played
myself in a game with black against the
GM last gym mats is six year and now I
got to the ending and TM I think white
is a little bit more comfortable black
should probably not go b5 as this
position is just very one-sided and not
very nice nice to play I can now decide
if I want to open up the a file or wait
I decided to wait it's just it's not
very interesting for back to play this
kind of situation here again now I felt
it's a good idea to keep the tension and
hope that he takes and he did take and
now before and I think it's very
comfortable
he should be three as an important tempo
and now would be one is a good
prophylactic against those two promise
and TNC for this is just pretty awful a
sixes hanging and he went a five but you
cannot really save it that was a bit of
us start/finish type of type of victory
the opening is just not there he comes
the low flow black honestly I wouldn't
even go into this ending in the first
place because it's so boring from black
and very much unattractive you can only
win if the opponent is doing something
really stupid but yeah I wouldn't I
wouldn't do that but you should play
probably and yeah something like this
and trying to shield or cover the dark
squares like that b5 is not not helpful
okay guys thanks for watching